Kim jongun l'a fait assassiner voici
l'histoire de Kim jongn le demi-frère
qui aurait dû être guide suprême de la
Corée du
Nord c'est un scénario digne d'un film
noir d'Hollywood personne n'est à l'abri
de Kim Jongen et tors de question de le
trahir si le demi-frère de Kim Jongen
peut-être assassiné à l'étranger alors
tout ressortissant nord-coréen peut
faire l'objet de
menace
cette semaine je vais vous raconter
l'histoire derrière un assassinat qui a
fait la une des journaux du monde entier
en 2017 à l'aéroport de kualalumpour en
Malaisie deux femmes aspergent le
demi-frère du dictateur nord-coréen avec
un agent neurotoxique avec cet acte Kim
jongun envoie un message fort il montre
qu'il est capable de frapper partout
tout le temps et même des membres de sa
propre
famille
nous sommes dans la matinée du 13
février 2017 à l'aéroport de
kualalumpour la capitale de la Malaisie
Kim Jong Nam le demi-frère du dictateur
coréen Kim jongun voyage sous le faux
nom de Kim Chol les caméras de
surveillance de l'aéroport de
kualalumpour le montrent traversant le
hall principal de façon assez
décontractée jusqu'à ce que deux
silhouettes arrivent alors qu'il attend
son vol pour MAAO il est par une jeune
femme quelques instants plus tard une
deuxième femme l'approche par derrière
et lui plaque un tissu imbibé d'un
fluide sur le visage Kim jongnam
redoutait fortement d'être l'objet d'un
attentat alors qu'il commence à
ressentir des vertiges Kim jongam se
dirige vers le comptoir d'information
pour demander de l'aide emmené à la
clinique de l'aéroport il est secoué par
des
convulsions pour comprendre comment on
en est arrivé là faisons d'abord un
petit
flashback Kim jongnam né en 1971 à
pongyong la capitale de la Corée du Nord
le régime nord-coréen il est difficile à
être qualifié ce qui est clair c'est que
c'est un régime extrêmement autoritaire
avec une spécificité c'està dire qu'il y
a à la fois des éléments communistes
socialistes et à la fois des éléments
innovants par rapport aux autres régimes
c'est-à-dire des régimes un régime
héréditaire on a aujourd'hui en Corée du
Nord une dynastie la dynastie Kim cette
dynastie est composée de trois
dirigeants Kim ilsong qui était le
premier dirigeant de la Corée du Nord
suivi de Kim Jong Hill son fils et de
Kim jongan l'actuel dirigeant Kim
jongnam est le fruit d'une liaison entre
l'actrice nord-coréenne songim et Kim
Jong Hill le fils du fondateur du régime
Kim hsong il est issu d'une famille du
côté de sa mère qui n'est pas une
famille euh bien placée dans l'échelle
sociale nord-coréenne quand Kim Jong
Hill est tombé amoureux de la mère de
Kim jongnam il a caché cette idile à son
père au cadre du régime Kim jongill
menace de faire exécuter quiconque parle
de sa vie privée Kim jnam grandit à
l'abri des regards mais partage des
moments privilégiés avec son père à
l'aide de faux passeports il se rentre
dans des parcs d'attraction au Japon Kim
jongnam a une enfance extrêmement
solitaire puisque il a vécu avec sa mère
sa grand-mère dans une propriété isolée
cette enfance choyée dans une sorte de
palais l'a complètement isolé du monde
réel et je crois qu'il en a souffert
toute sa
[Musique]
vie à la fin des années 80 kimjong Hill
s'éloigne de la mer de kimjong Nam et se
marie à une danseuse du nom de koyuni
ensemble ils auront trois enfants dont
Kim jongun Kim jongun est et Kim jongnam
n'ont rien partagé pendant leur jeunesse
donc ils n'ont pas de véritaable lien
alors ce sont déjà des demi frères qui
n'ont pas forcément été élevés ensemble
et donc on a a priori assez peu
d'interaction en Corée du Nord entre les
deux demi-frère à l'adolescence Kim
jongnam quitte la Corée du Nord pour
Genève afin de poursuivre ses
études en
1994 kimilsong meurt son fils Kim Jong
lui succède Kim hsong très tôt a annoncé
qu'il voulait que ce soit son fils qui
lui succède Kim jongil il a eu plusieurs
décennies pour préparer son arrivée au
pouvoir il a pu gravir les échelons
avoir des postes extrêmement importants
et donc le fait que ce soit le
successeur était entre guillemets un
acquis en tant que fils aîné du Guide
suprême Kim jongnam est destiné à
prendre la tête de la Corée du Nord à la
mort de son père Kim jongnam a été en
effet pressenti pour prendre la tête de
la Corée du Nord mais Kim jongill a été
assez déçu de la façon dont il gérait
les postes qu'on lui avait confié il est
tombé un petit peu en
[Musique]
disgrâce les dirigeants nord-coréens
notamment Kim Jongen quand il était
petit et Kim jongnam se sont rendus
plusieurs fois au Japon et à
Disneyland en 2001 va avoir 30 ans
accompagné de deux femmes et de son fils
de 4 ans il tente de se rendre à
Disneyland au Japon à son arrivée à
l'aéroport de Tokyo il est arrêté par
les autorités japonaises avec de faux
passeports dominicains après quelques
jours de détention il est finalement
libéré humilié sur la scène
internationale son père annule un voyage
diplomatique en Chine Kim jongnam est
définitivement écarté de la course à la
succession Kim jongill a été extrêmement
mécontent mais c pas la seule raison
pour laquelle kimong est tombé en dis en
fait il se sentait parfaitement inadapté
à la Corée du Nord et c'est à ce momentl
qu'il a souhaité s'exiler à
[Musique]
MAAO il meurt en 2011 c'est son trè fils
Kim jongun qui lui
succède du moment où Kim longongun
arrive au pouvoir il doit démontrer son
autorité et sa capacité à assurer la
stabilité du régime et un des événements
marquants c'est la façon dont le jeune
dirigeant s'est débarrassé en quelque
sorte de son oncle jongongtech qui était
de fait devenu le num numéro 2 du régime
qui était devenu extrêmement influent
Chang songtek a pris trop d'importance
il était très en faveur d'une politique
d'ouverture d'ouverture économique il a
accumulé pas mal d'argent il a utilisé
ses connexions personnelles à l'étranger
et Kim Jongen en a pris ombrage on a eu
une démonstration de force en décembre
2013 lorsque Kim Jong s'est débarrassé
de son oncle de façon extrêmement
médiatique extrêmement symbolique voit
Chang sonongtek la tête baissée être
arrêté en plein milieu d'une réunion
accusé de planifier un coup d'état
johnteek condamné à mort lors d'un
procès sommaire quelques jours plus tard
Kim jongun fait exécuter son oncle à la
mitrailleuse l'exécution de Chang
songtek a été mise en scène comme une
véritable pièce de théâtre c'était un
véritable message ce message était
destiné à tous les Nord-Coréens à
l'étranger pour leur dire attention il
ne faut pas me trahir puisque je suis
capable d'exécuter un traître même au
sein de ma propre
famille lorsque Kim jongun accède au
pouvoir Kim jongn vit toujours en exil à
MAAO avec sa famille certains amis de de
makao et de Hong Kong qui le
fréquentaient parle de Kim jongam comme
d'un bon vivant qui aimait profiter de
la vie qui aimait jouer de l'argent mais
qui n'avait pas véritablement d'envie de
remplacer Kim Jongen à plusieurs
reprises Kim jongnam s'exprime dans la
presse japonaise sur l'arrivée au
pouvoir de son demi-frère je pense que
c'est mon père qui l'a souhaité je n'ai
pas de regret ça ne m'intéresse pas ça
m'est égal personnellement je suis
opposé à une nouvelle succession
dynastique ça été un premier camouflé
que Kim Jongen n'a pas apprécié Kim
Jongen s'exprimé de façon un peu trop
visible sur le régime nord-coréen et sur
l'exercice du pouvoir de son frère la
dynastie ne fonctionne pas avec le
socialisme mon père y était également
opposé les dirigeants de Corée du Nord
n'aime pas qu'on raconte leur secrets et
Kim jongnam a commencé à être trop
locaste Kim jongnam bénéficier de la
protection de servic étrangers il a été
prouvé qu'il avait des contacts avec PAC
gunhe qui était la présidente de la
Corée du Sud et puis on l'a soupçonné
également d'avoir des liens avec la la
CIA donc tous ces liens un petit peu
occultes avec la Corée du Sud l'étranger
ces prises de parole un petit peu trop
pouvertes ont dé plusu à Kim Jongen d'où
cette raison de
l'éliminer à la clinique de l'aéroport
de kualalumpour Kim jongnam est secoué
par des convulsions il sera déclaré mort
à son arrivée à l'hôpital
body
l'autopsie révélera que Kim chongnam a
été empoisonné au VX un agent
neurotoxique extrêmement puissant une
seule goutte par voie cutanée peut tuer
une personne de 70 kg les deux femmes
qui l'ont aspergé avec l'agent toxique
ont été arrêté peu de temps après
l'enquête révélera qu'elles ont été dupé
par des agents secrets nord-coréens
elles pensaient piéger leur victime dans
le cadre du une émission de
télééalité 2 ans après l'assassinat
elles sont libérées par les autorités
malaisiennes encore aujourd'hui personne
n'a été condamné pour le meurtre de Kim
Jong Nam les agents nord-coréens repérés
sur les vidéos de surveillance ont
réussi à prendre la fuite de son côté
Kim jongun n'a jamais revendiqué
l'attentat en Corée du Nord il y a ce
qu'on appelle
la culpabilité par association à partir
du moment où une personne dans une
famille est soupçonné de trahison son
entourage et sa famille et elle aussi
coupable quelques semaines après
l'assassinat de Kim jongnam son fils
apparaît dans une vidéo publiée sur
YouTube
il est évident que le fils de Kim
jongnam et lui-même aujourd'hui
probablement en danger on sait pas où il
se trouve on sait qu'il a fait des
études en France à sciencep mais
aujourd'hui vit de façon anonyme à
l'étranger dans la crainte d'un
attentat
coréen merci à tous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo si vous êtes arrivés jusque
là j'imagine que c'est parce qu'elle
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à mettre un
like et à me dire ce que vous en avez
pensé en commentaire et aussi à me
donner des idées pour les prochains
épisodes si vous aimez ce genre
d'affaire je vous mets les liens des
vidéos sur le Rainbow Warrior et
l'espionne russe Anna Chapman vous
pouvez les retrouver également dans la
description un dernier mot pour
remercier toutes les équipes de brut qui
m'ont aidé à réaliser cette vidéo et sur
ce je vous dis à la semaine prochaine
pour une are grande
histoire